hello everybody I hope you are good
we're gonna talk about the madness that
we sold yesterday with this one hour
Candlestick that was two thousand
dollars down 2047 dollars down that's
insane and then we have this reduction
over here this bounce that it was a
bounce of another
1100 dollars so what we're gonna go
through what happened yesterday on the
next potential move for Bitcoin okay
well I haven't seen this sort of
Candlestick for a long time two thousand
dollars Candlestick what is that
they can see that they retrace Tuesday
move in one candlestick
insane well the first thing is that we
were marking this liquidity pool over
here that it got retraced and it was
exactly around the 30 000 level
psychological number and what I was
expecting to be honest was to break
above the thirty thousand dollars
because we had this over extended move
so the Bulls were loud and well Bulls
are loud price goes down the same as
when pairs are loud price goes up okay
so we were expecting price to go between
30 230 600 Consolidated over here and
then yes retrace because that would have
been the peak of Euphoria for the Bulls
imagine them oh yes we brought 30k next
is 40k okay you would have seen that all
over Twitter for example everybody would
be euphoric so that was my logic you
know make them euphoric after breaking
30k and then dump but no the market
maker just decided to go to 30k and a
straight thumb okay so that's why you
should always Mark these psychological
numbers specifically the whole numbers
30k
29 529
000 every 500 whatever one thousand
that's what I would recommend you okay
because you can see that in this in
those zones is when you usually see the
manipulation anyway enough talking about
what has already happened and let's talk
about what could potentially happen for
Bitcoin next so let's remove all of this
and what first is going to do a daily
time frame because with this I don't
know where we are right now I think we
are good let me check the 50ma yes we
are above support still in fact
yesterday we tested again the 50ma and
now we're filling this week over here
okay so that's quite interesting at the
moment you know we are kind of safe I
would say but let's go to the one hour
time frame again and let's see the
imbalances because this is something
very important
there are two ways to track this price
action okay you could have traded this
drop straight away okay if you did that
congratulations because that was a big
move or you could have trade the
imbalances for example look at this
large scandal
of two thousand dollars that's a massive
imbalance so you would expect Bitcoin to
start to retrace it now that's why it
did straight away okay so you could have
gone long at some point here to start to
retrace this Candlestick okay and now
we're in the Third Way of trading this
that I would say takes longer it's more
tedious it can be quite exhausting but
you can also trade it and it's trading
the imbalances that are left okay and
we're gonna try to do so so I would
start by marking the imbalances that I
can see to the upside I can see this
liquidity pool hasn't been fully
retraced so that would be one zone that
I'm interested
and also this week okay you might not
see that it's a big week compared to the
candle body but if you actually check
this is a how big
650 dollars move so it's a huge candle
candle no I meant weak sorry so let's
just have to Market that would be the
100 of the week and then this would be
about the 50 of the week let's name it
is so the chart is organized it's always
good to name your zones and to have the
chart organized so you can always know
why you mark that level and what you
were talking about in the past okay so
we have basically a liquidity pool to
the website of around three hundred
dollars okay quite small and then to the
downside we have this week that it's
very interesting now
how can we know what zone is gonna get
hit first I would suggest first to go
and check the SMP and the volar index
and the liquidations hit them up okay so
let's do that first
let's start with the dxy because
remember that Bitcoin trades against it
okay so let's go to the folder time
frame
okay I see a week already hang on what
happened yesterday
let's see oh I see so he almost came
back to this level okay that's quite
interesting you know I've I've been
telling you about this chart for a while
as long as the dxy doesn't make a lower
low then we're gonna expect a bounce in
this Zone okay but you can see that in
the four hour time frame
there is some massive week here so what
we would anticipate is that the dxy
should come lower to at least fill the
50 of the week of course you can go to
the hundred percent but at least 50
percent
and then potentially what's your bounce
okay so according to the theory
index goes down Bitcoin should have a
bounce in the short term so keep that in
mind now let's go for the SMP
here it is
all right yeah I have this chart quad
under control because I checked it this
morning but basically remember that we
have this white box that it was support
yesterday was yesterday you know two
days ago sorry he lost our support and
he went to this last Zone
but yesterday there was
quite a tricky move and it was that it
went below it
and if it goes below it
and breaks below this Zone we could see
the SMP going all the way to the 4 000
song which would be a massive drop
and I think Bitcoin would probably
follow okay but we'll probably not
should follow now let's go to the one or
time frame let's see what happened
because I can see that it's bouncing
again
and we are above support but the
structure here is telling me that
something might be happening printing at
the moment is
well we printed a lower low and now we
could be printing a lower high okay
because you can see that this high is
lower than this and this low is lower
than this one
so if that's to confirm then we could
expect the SMP to go lower and get to
have another less another leg down now
if we go to the 15 minutes time frame
because there is another alternative
what could be seen here is that if we
start seeing
the SMP some kind of sideways move
during the at the start of the New York
session something like this then well I
expect a move up so keep that in mind at
the moment it's not looking great also
you have here this kind of train line
that everybody is gonna start to draw
and when you see this type of drain of
train line well Traders usually do it's
something like this they're gonna be you
know opening Longs every time it teaches
train line because it work here
well here not because we still don't
have a train line it will work here it
work here so why not here okay and that
is in one of these moments when it's
gonna drop very aggressively to the
downside okay to trap those Traders
so keep an eye on this I think the SMP
could be forming
quite a very structure of lower lows and
lower highs it has to confirm and we
don't go above this high
four thousand ninety I would say that
are in this Zone then you would expect a
move lower but if we start seeing this
kind of sideways move during the start
of the New York session we would expect
a move high so keep this in mind okay
let's check out our recognition hit Maps
or great friend the liquidation of heat
maps and I'm sure it's gonna be very
messy in the 12 hours time frame after
yesterday's move yeah it's it's very
loud at the moment you can see you have
some liquidity at 29 875
which I think is maybe that liquidity
pool that we marked okay and to the
downside twenty seven thousand and 150
but this doesn't give us much
information because we are between two
large liquidity zones you know
yesterday's move were too aggressive so
there is liquidity at both sides now in
the seven days time frame
let's see if we find something more
interesting than the 12 hours time frame
you know the 70s time frame and the one
month time frame usually
are very good
charts oh my what is that let me check
this
okay
so apparently there is a lot of
liquidations at 32 650
and I'm guessing that that's because
yeah you can see that the this body
starts to go more yellow from here okay
and that's because in this move down
people would add into shorts okay all
well even more this in this area to be
honest if you check with the bar above
so in this Zone here
people are adding shorts okay but then
we have this liquidation the downside
that it's closer
and I also looks bigger a 26
850 that's below our week okay so there
is more liquidity be lower week now
let's go with this information to the
Bitcoin chart and let's draw a
projection we're back with the Bitcoin
chart and let's try to draw a projection
with all of the information from the vxy
the SMP the liquidation hit maps and I
know it's quite difficult because Asia
really didn't move and London isn't so
you know they're kind of consolidating
in this Zone and we could expect a move
to either side so it's kind of difficult
but what I would say that has more
probabilities to play out is that if we
see you know a pump first because the
dxy it seems like he might try to fill
to fill that week in the four hour time
France to the downside so then when the
v x y goes down between Bitcoin can go
up so I would like to see this first you
know fill this liquidity pool
and then we could see a dump okay where
to well or or and Target should be
I would say there are three targets here
okay for taking profits if this plays
out at the moment this is only
speculating because we haven't even got
here I kind of even see the momentum and
the strength of the move
so this is only speculating at the
moment but I would say that we have
three potential take profits if this
happened well the first one would be the
week 50 of the week and the full week so
that would be I usually take most of my
profit most of my profits at the 50
percent of the week so that's 27
575 then we also saw in the liquidation
heat Maps remember in the seven days
time frame that there is Kuala liquidity
in this Zone below at twenty six
thousand eight hundred fifty okay so
this is another area of Interest so
price could come a bit lower
and then if we go to the four hour time
frame let's check that 50 EMA
because I've just noticed that something
very interesting is happening here
all right pay attention to this
you know what we all what we usually
look for is you know
a push-up of the EMA retrace practice
and support and continue the way push up
okay here I didn't happen didn't teach
their support so it went higher and then
it fell very strong yesterday remember
and couldn't test it 50 MAF support so
he went lower now that was last night
now Wednesday at 8 pm UTC time we see a
move high but still it hasn't tested the
50 EMA support
so I think sooner or later between has
to test it
I don't know if it's gonna go up first
and then come back down but for sure
this has to be as soon that Bitcoin has
to has to come down to okay that's right
now 28
344 you can see in the top left okay 28
344. so that would be our first tech
profits if Bitcoin can hit this Zone
first then I would open a short okay and
I will be aiming first the 50m in the
four hour time frame then the week and
finally the liquidity the original
liquidation heat maps at 26 850.
it's not Financial advice it's only my
personal opinion my personal projection
I'm I'm just here planning speculating a
potential next story that I might take
and that's all it is so guys thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you
soon